hello and welcome to this video playing
I am tick-tock Ted rock and alone
difficult for me yeah so symmetrical
English with black see what is playing
here this is a big decision on move 6
what white white can play all kinds of
things so here I actually played this
move I really have forgotten how this
works
think this one it's been a while since
they looked at it or the you porn and
now it's a kind of clearly too late yeah
it's not exactly what I wanted here why
does a little bit better do I take with
the you poncey txt file is already not
do not the main line may I take with the
pawn down and looked at this for wow
yeah still this is not completely
terrible for black but white has this
Catalan like bishop on g2
yeah it looks kind of like looks like
the normal move um yeah okay Oh mr.
sophisticated yeah interesting you can
see one is a very sophisticated way of
doing it maybe it's good so job he will
have pretty nice pressure and can I do
something else they're taking home it's
not going to be easy to develop
[Music]
and it's not great really not I know how
this looks but I have to develop some Oh
Bishop d7 c 6-r i prevented okay
Jim what has all kinds of it he has
night b5 b6 and yeah maybe maybe he
finds something better even yep that
looks fine
maybe I can just about untangle
[Music]
it should be seven but what would have
been some kind of self pen yeah so that
makes sense
okay after we turn upon yeah I mean I
think this should lead to some trades
and hopefully equality I'm still a
little bit coordination is not ideal
that same you know I don't want to blame
him probably Roxy ain't yeah that looks
solid check Joe draw our third game
drawn yeah um that was a risky thing
here probably to take on b2 and
everything ok so see takes something I
did wrong Bishop c5 is suggested by the
engine yeah that makes sense him why not
I don't know i would have to check this
i mean here i think why definitely looks
to be a bit better and this is was an
interesting try just give up the pawn
takes takes maybe I should take
immediately this is uh I don't know that
was a clever idea engine suggest we
should be seven yeah I wasn't sure if
this is good or not to take one go back
and well I decided to take it and now
nitey am it's not not the nicest move
above it I didn't really see how to
untangle my position
yeah maybe this I can do maybe this is
better the likelihood of drawing is
probably relatively high yeah I can
check with the rook there's something
that the trades down everything like the
line that the engine is giving here for
example looks fairly am fairly logical
unless I have some immediate issue yeah
but I think I can something like that
should be it should be it wrong so here
we go to this totally enjoyable position
yeah probably a relatively correct game
I am need to improve on the opening and
this kind of position looks a little bit
uncomfortable okay thanks for watching